it is truly tough to find straight pups
in animal shelter because the animal
foundation has not been taking them in
over three weeks thank you for joining
us at 11 I'm Brian Loftus and I'm Denise
Valdez so now some of the other shelters
are simply at capacity and Animal
Control doesn't know what to do with the
stray dogs that they come and get every
day Ryan Matthew joining us now in
studio with how this continued closure
is impacting all of us yeah Denise Bryan
the Nevada SPCA for example they
typically do not accept stray dogs they
would normally direct the people to the
animal foundation who has the government
contract to take care of them but three
weeks after a virus outbreak closed all
dog intakes and limited dog adoptions
getting a man's best friend reunited is
hard
finally get the dogs two big dogs
friendly but all over the place Annie
Lebon thoughts drive to work Sunday took
a turn
she found these two dogs with no collar
and no chip but when she called Clark
County Animal Control Animal Control
said um there's really nowhere you can
take them I said what do you mean leave
the dogs there she says the operator
told her the county confirmed that his
quote currently not responding to calls
about stray dogs because of the
pneumovirus outbreak at the animal
foundation which infected over 70 dogs
and closed its dog intake on October 3rd
I'm like well I don't understand this is
what you're there for what what do I do
I'm a citizen with no space at home and
no luck at other rescues her only option
to board them at a nearby vet she says
and with no medical records it cost her
over two hundred dollars to vaccinate
and board them we're getting over 50
calls a day that's the best case
scenario Nevada SPCA executive director
Laura Heron can hope for right now
with space for 250 animals she says
they've been over capacity for weeks
going as far as taking in this dog after
metro police arrested its owner and
didn't know where to shelter it a small
staff facing a huge crisis we are
overwhelmed and it can't continue it's
not sustainable we need to start getting
some answers about when they're going to
reopen and what the solutions are going
to be
now a spokesperson for the animal
foundation says that they are only
accepting dogs in The Last Resort
scenario no word yet on when the full
adoption and intakes will resume the
foundation also announced today that
they will be fully closed on Monday
starting next week for staff training
reporting live here in studio Ryan
Matthew 8 News Now